it's alright our powers have combined
last point is is is the thing he bought
is flash point returns man what is going
on how you doing sir oh pretty good
pretty good just you know getting to the
end of a week just not enough time to do
all the things in destiny but had got a
nice little checkbox done this week so
that was pretty cool got a completely
surprising one I'll get into a little
bit later but yeah it just a really
really busy busy weekend destiny so
we'll get into everything that's going
on what about you men didn't get a
chance to play baby
wanted to get like like at least a whole
weekend I got I got maybe two two days
in a couple of hours here a couple hours
there so wasn't the type of blaze I
wanted you know saying but um you know I
got to touch a little bit and we
definitely got to get into those topics
as far as what's going on with uh
this current week right it's just so
much it's so much to do man it's like
over whelming and I had limited time on
top of it I'm not happy I gotta get some
wood that's the absolutely lot of stuff
going on and um just wanted to start off
real briefly um as far as like kind of
like a brief channel update you don't
say as far as what's going on with the
lords and everything like that obviously
been living under a rock haters the
announcements kind of went out on social
media and you know in fact pretty much
effective immediately we're gonna be
doing a lot of the pretty much the ILP
content on the ILP channel so the the
podcast before was on tick we're now
gonna do it alive on Sundays the Lord's
Day will return here flashpoint will
remain here as well as a combat talk
with the king and other stuff we got
cooking and um I definitely want to give
a shout out to the entire ticket network
you know everyone over there whether it
be the affiliates the writers the
website I mean it's been tremendous man
tremendous love it's no beef nothing
like that it's just a mutual decision
and um one thing I really want to say is
those guys really really rock with us
we've been here for a couple years and I
really want to send a salute to the team
and to thank you for the opportunity you
know saying absolutely Kyle you know
Santa I got a lot of friends over there
man you know saying I'm dad Brad all
these guys you know saying I really want
to shout these guys out because at the
end of the day those guys help make me
better also a pleasure working with them
so it's gonna be cool man it's gonna be
cool looking forward to the future
we got a lot of stuff planned for ILP so
I'm excited about that and a team and
you know flash planning going on with so
yeah that's what to get that out and I
get much love to the tick Network and
like I said please stay tuned for ILP
still got a lot of stuff cooking still
got some some grand ideas that we're
trying to get off the ground and just
stick with us on our journey man and
that's pretty much I wanted to say on
the business side but um yeah man other
than that like I said it's just destiny
and all these games coming out looks
like what we got Red Dead next weekend
oh man you know Call of Duty this week
and call it who looks good did you get a
chance to see any that stuff I got Call
of Duty you picked that one up because a
friend of mine they're playing at a
pretty good amount I played like one
round of zombies that was a completely
different start but kind of cool the
blackout is just fun it's honestly like
a polished version of pub G and for me
it's it's honestly like it just it feels
pretty good there's nothing that I'm
like I mean nothing's gonna be perfect
by any means but I think what up G did
you have the military shooter version of
like polish and a couple more vehicles
in there that helicopters kind of fund
actually had like projectiles as opposed
to hitscan on things I mean it just it
has kind of a cool field of the game so
it's a twist on Call of Duty and then on
top of that you see somebody like skill
up doing his review saying like
multiplayer section just the good old
you know PvP stuff is some of the best
it's felt it's kind of a quirk their
modern where for to like on board with
ecology and it's just like you know it's
crazy so I mean it's old what was it
five hundred million on the first day
like the number that I saw sitting out
there so that one's crazy and then you
got Red Dead which is the only thing
that has upset Call of Duty in the past
forever so so much so did they move
their release date
I mean everybody's moving around you see
I mean the stuff coming out the news
about the hundred hour weeks which then
all impacts and not so much no and you
sure I mean you hear about crunch and
you know it's kind of a thing in
programming and gaming especially for
the developers and stuff like that but
it sounds like a lot of the ones have
come out and said it's like you know
there may be some overtime it's like
could be asked never been close to 100
maybe it more than normal but I mean
you're gonna have some of those times
but it sounds like I mean unless they're
just picking and choosing whose answers
which of course it could be I mean you
never know you know have I got a story
in general it sounds like a lot of
people do enjoy it Bart is what's
happenin News ready to branch off do
that game and news channel s and I I
stay on top of it I just keep every word
no I have nothing left
thank you you just like knocked it out
the park there's gonna be a talking
point for IOP at one point as well but
um yeah man I'm complete agreement with
you you know you know crunch is part of
the game and again like you said you
know you never can tell with these
things you know saying you know you know
like some people agree with the
accountant you know some people like
that the conditions are not like that
you know and their personal thing
sometimes maybe it's in a little but at
the end of the day you know at least as
an IT guy you know say I can speak for
myself that you know when you have big
big projects or big migrations and big
releases and stuff like that it is kind
of assumed that there's going to be a
period of crunch where you're expected
to you know do extra work and stuff like
that so you know hopefully these guys oh
well from what I was told you know get
ot and do all that good stuff and and
get compensated for their work and
hopefully it's not like any type of year
long thing and hopefully this thing's
just overblown but at the end of the day
a good game seems to be birthing out of
this you know
yeah story is what oh my god yeah I
almost was gonna make that a segment for
flashpoint I was in talk to you which
was like you know the in the pending
competition like I was obviously you
know we have the these things we may as
well start a big net go for it let's do
a Long Point little tangent and
yeah because you know it's so funny
listen to our mentality now their
destinies in a good place
right mm-hmm because I remember these
conversations
don't believe me I know to like February
morrow
I know I know how skeptical I was
because I know how much needed change
yes and honestly Bungie like they put
the work in they've yes and hats off to
those guys out there but yeah probably
still no words again so go for it yeah
bet I mean it's one of those things that
it's just like I guess it gets goes to
show you that when the game is in place
you know how we're not as fearful like
before we were like oh my god read dad's
coming call it oh he's gonna get
pushback you know at that time we didn't
know when division with launch or
whatever right so it was like you know
if that's what is it gonna do it's gonna
get smile it up you know it's so funny
that like I said again not saying that
nobody's not playing call dude nobody's
not saying that you know that's these
numbers are going past that but it's in
such a good place right now at least in
my opinion that um people are okay like
yep these games here this distant you
know Odyssey came out that was another
great one right a lot of people very
underrated you know kind of thing so um
yeah it's just real interesting to see
you know that's they continue to do the
right thing and still kind of
maintaining its place but what do you
feel you know with destiny now in the
mix with all these releases kind of
popping up around it I mean I think they
still have that good timeframe September
is good for them because it gets them
ahead of a lot what starts as a they're
almost one of the first things of the
fall yes and it puts them in a good spot
because it is a more time consuming game
there's no question about it
because of the grind the leveling the
different activities and then forsaken
through the everything at the wall and
it all stuck yes there was so much stuff
to do in forsaken it had some decent
space to breathe that's had some time
with the raid you've had these
activities now the stuff that we keep
finding in the game it's had some nice
legs to it that it stayed relevant long
enough but no other stuff is going to
come I mean you got Call of Duty that's
definitely gonna I mean it's um it's in
and it's one of the biggest in the world
it always probably will be until
something crazy happens but Treyarch
seems to have done really well this
yeah Red Dead coming battlefields coming
but then so you're gonna have all that
time for all that stuff to sit and
simmer and then go on and then all the
people who may have been like hey I got
my destiny in doing this all that had a
really good experience and forsaken they
just opened up so if you by forsaken you
don't have to buy the other old
expansions like another in the right
direction
yes so that's all good steps and then
you go to the fall and and we're like
okay we're doing good we're doing good
okay a whole bunch of games people gonna
step away December is gonna come I think
that's gonna be the first tell of what
the Annual Pass does Emery some people
are probably like a four-second sounds
pretty good it's the only forty bucks
it's cool I'm not gonna do the annual
pass yet and that's probably where a lot
of people are at I have a feeling you
got the diehards like us I've already
bought it all it's fine but there's
definitely plenty of people they're just
gonna be on the fence and be like hey
I'm just buying forsaken there's so much
stuff I don't know if I got time or I
want to wait and see if they earn the
Annual Pass mmm so let me ask you a
follow-up question do you think that
because of we can we can agree that you
know forsaking was very well received
right oh yeah and um you know it created
a lot of goodwill in the community and
for I would say I won't say casuals but
you know people who like destiny who
went away and then we could say that you
know a lot of that a good destroyed
percentage of that time came back what
forsaken do you think because of the
goodwill earned by forsaken that that
would just get people to arm say you
know what man I'm really enjoying this
concert so much I give him that black
Armory money or do you kind of agree
with kind of go back to what you that
kind of alluded to which was you know
they still might be wait and see with
this additional content but you got
telling you my guts the latter honestly
okay so I mean the goodwill is a good
thing it gives people an idea to look
he's even dusty to I mean when you
stepped out you didn't have the weapon
slots pick so PvP didn't always quite
feel that great and the double primary
has kind of got a little I don't want to
say boring but it didn't have like the
flare but sometimes you wanted in just
your typical gameplay and it just felt
like it was missing something I mean and
well the campaign actually had kind of a
cool progression the lit the raid wasn't
connected we've talked about that before
but I mean the story itself was kind of
cooled it was just it was more destiny
and everybody likes that but it didn't
have the link the legs the deep grind
the randoms weren't there so many knees
were missing that it was like people
could fall off that wagon easier now
forsaken will keep it more but we have
even bigger competition probably this
year than we did last year for our
attention but I think it's still in a
pretty good place that when people say
hey what's the review on black are more
alike is that actually coming out pretty
good cool okay you know give me like a
week or so check the reviews okay I'll
still probably pick it up I think they
have built up enough like good reviews
and word and things like that to say
okay if this is what for seconds like
it's pretty solid great foundation new
activity with gambit and all that stuff
going on and then if somebody says you
know I June comes back and says like hey
black Army's not quite for sake and
obviously forsaken not so much out of
the part hey we got 88.5 or something
for black armor a pretty solid expansion
cool activities that might be that step
that says okay I think Bungie is
actually headed in a proper direction
more people will start opening that wall
at for the annual pass but it is
probably for me not me specifically but
for a lot of people I see it's gonna
take those reviews on black army but
that's really like just the point old I
can see that I can see becomes one with
that I can see where you come from
that's fair enough fair enough
what about you I mean what about you do
you think it's just like hey they're
good you should just totally buy it I
mean personally I have faith at this
point but I understand most people have
been burned
what's your circle telling you my circle
is telling me like obviously there's
still so much the forsaken people still
have a finished right they still tend to
be with us to have another rate you
don't say there's still tons of people
so I can see my gut is telling me that
it may very well still be a wait and see
for the hard core is the hard core we're
getting it regardless right this doesn't
affect us but the people that middle
missing you know what I still got stuff
to do I ain't finished in unless war
mine shows something and we'll talk
about later
you know rumors and stuff like that that
is like so like they show one
that is like so like almost I want to
say is the level of K or something like
that but they have to stay would have to
show something you know really impactful
to get people to go whoa I gotta find
out what's going on and I'm not sure my
gut tells me right now that's a hard
thing to live up to after forsaking my
gut tells you like it probably solid you
know I'll be good but I don't know hope
is gonna have like a wall cage day you
know all this other stuff that forsaken
came with so uh it'll be interesting my
gut probably is with you it's gonna be a
hard core yes the casuals maybe and if
the reviews come out and compound that
it's good then they'll be right back in
pocket okay I got you yeah yeah so I
mean like in a couple in couple got you
know said Fred and Oscar both of my chat
just basically saying hey it's like I'm
on watch just got to wait they're not
getting there and that's the thing a lot
of people got burned with Osiris
yeah first expansion and that's why for
this annual pass to do well they
probably have to put the most effort
into black armory yeah that has to be
the best of the three I'm asking because
I mean you got a you got to step out
with the right foot to people for people
to think that the other two are getting
even hold a candle to being worth it yes
now granted I mean the other two
expansions were if you bought them
together they were 30 but if you bought
them separate they were 40 is that how
those work before yeah I believe so I
mean so we are getting to three things
now two are gonna have raid layers one
is that whole gambit revamp in the
middle for Joker's wild so that one's
kind of like the I don't know the
oddball of the bunch because it doesn't
feel like a full expansion to me I mean
I think I'm curious about that because I
mean the drifter is cool for sure but
it's more the what it has to offer
doesn't feel as I don't want to say full
I'm trying to figure out the way but you
don't know what I mean basically
basically on what you've perceived what
you've seen so far about Joker's wild
you personally
not think it may match black armory you
know I'm seeing or penumbra yeah yeah I
made those two they've said they're
gonna be raid layers it's like those can
potentially be cool if they even hold a
remote candle I mean last wish is just
awesome so all of those pieces sound
really really cool but then you've just
got to be like okay so what is what's
the deal so I mean up here we got you
know the first piece with black armor
you've got this trailer with this guy up
here it's like gaunt we've her watch him
yeah that's like a weird name you know
excellent no no yeah sorry XO no number
so like the plan here we have like
launch is crazy yes gambit raid last
wish
iron banners here crucible matches lost
lost has been we'll get to our thoughts
on that one and then just more so weekly
playlist updates the dreaming said
evolution and additional surprise we've
had a lot those like your first piece
you have the daunting event having
machine guns are coming back we'll talk
about that new weapons new crucible
content iron banner gameplay update
season ranks all that stuff's just kind
of there but you've got so the black
armory this essentially is going to be
those new weapon types basically you've
got like weapons which seems really
weird to me the very interesting another
weapon literally type so you got a
legendary exotic rare and black and
you're just like are these and
everybody's in their mind going like
okay exotics or exotics what are these
things usable as exotics can you only
have one one of them yeah I see what
what properties apply what rules happen
right so this is this is very very
gameplay system changing on some levels
so we definitely got to see how that
works
yeah so then we've got new forges of the
chain activity and so I mean the
activity a lot of people think blind
well so I mean you've got kind of a
horde mode wave stuff like that and
that's kind of one of those pieces and
when escalation protocol is done right
if you have a decent cut like a few
people out there now and as we're a
little bit over leveled it's a little
more manageable an escalation protocol
is still really really cool it's a fun
experience like each one of the bosses
each week rotates they have different
activities so all those pieces are cool
there but like blind well the more you
do it you kind of get the feeling like
okay it doesn't quite have the same
pizzazz
I guess yeah see what do I think the
heroic version is cool cuz you got the
three you turn on and you can to do the
boss it's got its different mechanics
and stuff like that so that's kind of
that like addition it needs to kind of
go in the level that escalation protocol
is I'm wondering if this is gonna be one
of those type or if it's gonna be more
of say forces of the chain say it's like
a haunted forest type right let's go
question this is a good question I'm not
sure I mean they've been pretty solid
with these introduction of new
activities so um you know I'm willing to
give it a shot there you know I'm very
curious I'm very curious um you know
it's one of these we gotta just see it
man it's gonna be hard to determine we
just gotta see it you know and like you
said I am a fan of escalation protocol I
still like I like the going in there now
that I'm all the levels it feels so good
I remember the struggle during the war
mine you know whatever like cap days so
you know anytime I get a chance to stop
stuff out feel it's wrong but always
welcome to activities dynasty which the
stains gonna be man I'm very curious
about it yeah so I mean it's just kind
of one of those two wait and see what
that is entailed what is our little
teaser gonna be sometime in November
we're gonna hear about what is involved
we know array layer they're just gonna
yep there's a red layer we're not gonna
tell you anything that's the whole
surprise new legendaries which I
honestly can't wait for that we need we
need a bit more need a bit more variety
in that weapon pool because at this
point I am on like you know my my sixth
trust my redundancy yep
so it was like they're the randoms are
goods like I like the fact that the
rules are there it gives you some
options makes me try different things
and stuff like that you know there's
eventually gonna be a meta but that pool
needs bigger so I can't wait for that to
get here
Triumph's collections bonus
words all that good stuff fine yeah that
forges of the chain I think is gonna be
the biggest piece and then just I guess
whatever the depth of this black armor
is going to be so between those the raid
layer and if there's just enough more to
do I mean if they add more exotic quests
if they have like a new gambit map if
they have that they need enough in this
one to make it worth it it's at least
ten dollars but in a lot of people's
mind if they do this they're like is
this worth 30 and that's gonna write
yourself right absolutely absolutely
we ended in their defense I don't see it
listed but I was on the impression that
the season that trials missed is this
one right so technically
eery trials should be coming back for
black armory cuz that's a new season
right isn't that considered a new season
yeah it should be a new season but
that's also if they have it done yeah if
it's done I mean ever done but one would
go up at some point during black armory
that trial should make its return so
again even though I know they're not
mentioning it right now and probably
like you said to protect deliverables
protect dates to make sure they can
actually get whatever they're trying to
revamp conclude on but my gut is telling
me you know they did say it was gonna
miss a season armories the season a new
a new season so maybe not at the very
beginning maybe in during the middle of
it we may see it haha you know you know
we just call the nines back or who knows
what version of that you also got
faction rallies those are at least on
hiatus until they pick some and we still
haven't heard anything about that joke
festival lost wraps up on almost it's
just getting started we've got a couple
more weeks of that will be in November
and some point in December the season
loss is gonna be the season I lost one
of my sayings your average but it can't
be that late in December it's not gonna
come out on like December 25th right
like the 10th the 15th of the beginning
of the second week I would say so
something like that so you there's not
that much time to do something like
faction around literally bring them back
and announce them and unless they do
like a test or something but it feels
like that's almost gonna fall under this
as well so I mean they've got they still
have things cooking
said you got trials that I totally
forgot about faction rallies that we
still haven't come back and like if they
fix those two as well that's just more
stuff going on so absolutely
just real quick Justin workman in my
chat he said he's not just eat like be
nice to see unique intrinsically Church
like the knight for weapons with the
introduction of black weapons that are
orangey rolled I'm with you what you
feel about like the intrinsic exotic
like certain legendaries have a specific
perk plus the random roles yeah yeah I
mean I'd love like they they have to do
something to make themself set apart
like maybe you can throw you know maybe
there's an extra perk slot or maybe
there is some intrinsic thing to this
you know black auto rifle that's gonna
have an extra mod slot or something yeah
they gotta give give them a reason to
make them stand apart if I can throw
like counterbalance you know
counterbalance and boss back on there
that's that's the type of stuff where
you're really gonna start to be able to
get some distinction between your
weapons which would be cool absolutely
absolutely I'm which you man great great
idea Justin work when I'm which man yeah
so then in spring we see the season in
the drifter so new weapons stuff like
that by the way totally completely like
blew past this by the way with machine
guns coming back and block let's go talk
about this before it's like I was like
having a long clip of a powerful gun
that he Zuzu drop somebody in PVC and
fill power of it but dude what do you
think how do you think this is gonna
change stuff up do you think it's gonna
be able to I don't know I was like I
enjoyed them in there certain spot but I
feel like they never really had quite
their place in PV e e yeah PvE no no it
this was clearly a PvP weapon um I don't
think they could do too much with a PvE
I mean let's look at the heavy slot
right let's analyze it you know right
now Rockets got super good it's the
current whisper it's a sleeper in
whisper world that's what it is right
and actually gotta give them you gotta
give my boy credit come on e my favorite
weapon has got to be the number one most
dominant thing since Gjallarhorn give it
up give it up
sleepers about favorite with this is
probably the most dominant I've seen it
because most people I don't know if it's
because sure okay but that's kind of the
point I mean it ear not wrong there's
nothing that compares to it generally
with the power that it can do the clip
size that it has yes and just what it's
capable of do nothing can compare to
that damn gun and yeah I'm not arguing
that it's a good gun I'm just saying it
it does limit your options like you're
gonna run with sleeper what's the point
in the other two slots having exotics I
mean that's kind of the part where
sometimes it's almost Opie enough to
wear it like ruins your choices no I
have choice so no you did not Jimbo
sleeper destroys everything even fun
itself you do not besmirched a great
name sleep a match of gambit that
doesn't have sleeper and then you turn
around and play one where there's two or
three sleepers on maybe either side that
is a different game mode with and
without one gun like night from halfway
across the map you're earned it because
you had to crit me no but have you have
you had have you gone in a game but
without sleeper ever without it is we're
like I was trying to test out an on
guard role bad omens it I was like let
me see how it is but just tracking it no
custom walk I love you see how it is
because the bones are no track you don't
seem like like what I try to debut a
legendary setups now though trouble's
not doing like when I try to debut a
legendary would a decent role and see
you know saying but yes you are correct
sleeper is by my side like a crutch I
can't go outside with it I can't I can't
get that work without the slate it's
that an escalation protocol shock now
I've been trying to other things out of
that slide to get me out of that fix you
know I'm saying of EP shotgun you know
and that's a little bit more
you know a little bit more managers not
more of as addicting I can kind of get
away with it when you mix up Connecticut
Nam and energy but when it comes down to
pure boss DPS like you said when it
comes down to doing you know a vintage
what I would call it a vintage
he bonds his solo run oh so I gotta keep
it yes I am guilty as charged
I am busted it is the only heavy
powerslide weapon I am using and
selfishly I'm smiling and I know
probably a nerf is another nerves
probably coming but it just reminds me
of like Yoda Gjallarhorn days and I'm
but I never thought it would happen with
my favorite weapon so it's kind of funny
yeah I mean it's fun to enjoy it well
it's there if you're gonna if you want
to win you got to be part of the meta I
mean that's just there are some the one
I will honestly say though I had one of
the best moments in gambit recently and
sleeper wasn't involved because it was
when the meatball spawned I had that
dude spawn for the first time and I
about lost I got had a heart attack
first because for one shout out to my go
figure that thing is a laser beam I will
use my go figure one I invade on that
first one and mess some people up that
thing is a beast and people have been
watching my video saying go figure it
must be really nice on PC because it
does not feel like this on coms like
mine feels real good but I had the
meatball spawn I didn't know it spawned
until I came back from invasion
literally had no idea it was there I was
like okay I was shooting I'm working on
I had my Twilight oath I sniped a guy
from across the map messed him up I came
back and I saw the meatball and my heart
went through about 4,000 different mix
and one second I was like okay what do
we do what do we do we both had our both
headed up they started pulling ahead
dude so I was like alright sweet I'm
going back in went in honestly just
started picking on with go figure
go figure okay cool got him going went
back again I went back for that third
invasion
I went folding the coat of the missile
crossed half the day I'm map knocked one
guy out threw a grenade as I was leaving
the grenade killed a guy
got the kill finally got the health just
high enough for us to burn him down
and I got my shattered heart but I've uh
mine marrying that one dude so jealous
bro
I also screwed some people over cuz
that's the point
well cuz I healed the game I healed the
primeval 96% his big that's like you get
hate messages at that point well things
about Battlement you have to actually
add for instance agem so those but I
probably definitely made some people mad
but I mean that that moment that's like
I knew this was gonna come up because I
had that moment I was like come on go
ahead I got that one more kill alright
come on burn it down shoot it shoot it
just even in my chair in my own little
head is just getting there probably 11
o'clock at night : like I had that fist
pump moment guys loved it felt so good
and meanwhile some of us are constantly
yet to see the meatball or get anything
honestly I was like I'm gonna say huge
giant amount of luck that's the only
time I've seen it after playing a pretty
good amount of gambit when I probably
see it again for a while because that
patch is coming in to end but a week and
a half it is what it is you know say and
shout out to you you got you you know
that part of the quest line to get it
going
I don't mind I mean I'm gonna get out of
the game but I played it the key is
gonna be because you gotta win you know
how's that gonna go especially if he
anywhere and oh oh Lord
so you know good luck to that yeah I got
it with randoms like they were working
all of a sudden it's like I realized
okay they're working those so I just
started invading over and over and that
was literally my job so nice like in a
my chat scene the meatball four times
killed it twice wow that must be nice
how many Forsaken exotics you guys got I
got my second Trinity ghoul does that
make you mad oh I just want I just want
like either the Phoenix Protocol just
one warlock exotic what was some I don't
know what I don't want to care for a
weapon if I get it to be odd I really
want an exotic I tell you what you know
two three either for the void the UM the
arm piece what is it uh I think you have
it the one of controversy up
controversial
I want to geomatic stabilizers but
basically the three new exotics that
would synergize good with my warlocks
new class of classes you know say so
just like ah matter of fact the only
weapon is shout-out to Chris comer to
chat the only weapon I do want badly oh
I do want that two-tailed Fox shad the
Crisco he said he got his yesterday yeah
I do want that one I didn't get that
yeah so I mean it's there's a whole lot
of Raynham to it believe me it's like
the fact that I saw it and killed it
honestly I just 100% assumed that when I
saw it I was anyone gonna have a chance
cuz I always play randoms so I honestly
really did not expect even get a shot at
like getting the kill and then it just
had that game and had that moment I was
just like damn it actually I mean it was
but just in that moment
by the way shout-out guys too if you
haven't heard just because we there's
not a lot about interviews with those
guys two of the gambit main leads
Guardian radio got an interview with
them so I so I got about 30 minute an
interview with those guys and it's just
cool to hear them basically the cool
thing about it is they explained how
that whole thing came about the
development of it the things that they
tested there wasn't even an over shield
at first there wasn't even seeing
through walls at first so I mean they go
through and kind of explain all the
testing that showed how it that's where
it is which was actually really cool so
that one's a cool interview just if you
are curious about the game-mode and it's
kind of origins the testing it went
through how it started out in just the
different pieces there wasn't even a
primeval for a while why even exist
wow I was like and there's certain
pieces you hear and like it's hard to
think of the game mode without all the
pieces it has so it's just kind of cool
to hear the story that it went through
so that was that was kind of a cool
listen cool but yeah you've got Joker's
wild for this I mean how are they and
it's gonna evolve question your life
stuff like they're gonna be you know you
know patching and like let me warn y'all
now let me make a public service and
service announced or you didn't you
sleep a hatin heathens know there's a
mean going out right now I believe it's
Rick cactus has it is the funniest meme
I should have all saved it in screenshot
it and
like uh it has like two sleeper simulant
right and it's like honey I thought
you're rid of me right and they're
behind it it has like Queens breakers
bro and I've got it I've heard something
like that and it's like I'm sorry what
oh yeah oh you're mad about sleeper and
Queens breakers boughs like hold my beer
hold my beer right now man I haven't
seen that at all but I've heard some
picked off with it like like twice yeah
water yeah dad you know if you wish for
be careful what you wish for because
there's some things cooking at people
and reddit or like it's our little
secret and Queens breakers bro is
definitely on that list of being
obnoxious and gamut warning yeah now I
hunted recent believe you cuz I've heard
a couple things as well just little
whispers as you say then it's not
popular because it's not a full quest
it's still random drops for eating for
that stuff to like start getting more
into the mix but I've heard some people
say Queens breakers
which is interesting to me because I
remember it so much from do one being
kind of only okay because you're trying
to like sniper the fusion rifle you have
to lead him you have to wait for the
charge time and while it's doable it was
mm-hmm
it's still different so I don't know how
hard it hits like what it's able to do a
shout to just what he said Queens
breakers has some cute big hit boxes for
people cried about sleeping eating
giggles that's right good you ride with
me my selfish weapon that's right with a
backhoe but uh as far as the young like
you said with Joker's wild
it is interesting right like what could
they do to the gameplay mode that
they're gonna expand upon it right so
I'm very curious about that deals I
think I'm low key more excited about
chokers well because I think badly it'll
be fun I don't know why I think the
Driftless story is very interesting I'm
not gonna say he's gonna be a character
that's gonna replace a cane but um you
know it is just one of the things that
I'm very curious about his whole
with the Lightning dog don't get me
wrong he's gone thing sounds mysterious
and cool and we got to see what's going
on with the weapons and should we get to
the rumors now I want to talk about it
later with black armor I mean yeah f
what heads-up spoiler alert couple
potential spoilers so I turned away for
like I don't know two minutes we'll try
anything quick yeah three two one all
right go for it yes so the rumors are
you know that we should absolutely gonna
see the Thunder Lord soon but the rumors
are what black army know we're supposed
to be getting icebreaker back which is
very interesting because as we know that
is probably one of the most hardest guns
in the history of destiny balance so for
them to bring that back man it would it
would require a severe revamp to make it
fair because that game could that gun
can literally break the game let's just
keep it much as I love it I mean as you
spawn with - yeah yeah so you got that
and then that's we warned you it's
really Oh
the second one is the one that we most
likely thought based on laws definitely
good old last word Tech's mechanic is
owned the fast firing Red Dead
Redemption style you know wild wild west
that was my favorite exactly true
confession that was my first love one of
the first ones I ever got I really loved
last word I just love that number two
animation with the hand off the top II
he's just flicking like that yeah that
was I never used that but I was terrible
at that gun I was a beast with it I fell
in love with hand cannons first and last
word was very special piece um again
very curious to see how it will come
back to see how it will enter that meta
so black armory you know it fit the name
fits it's good it's going to have those
exotics is gonna happen could be
interesting yeah what you thought yeah I
mean black armor sounds cool heavy
machine guns like I mean just the fact
but thunderlord's come about not even
some Thunder Lord I cannot remember the
name of the damn gun in d1 it was one of
the later heavies that was smaller and
he'd basically
tap people in PvP Oh was it the raid one
that's when we talk about maybe Willems
was one there was another one I had that
was slower and I'd honestly just have to
look through my old vaults and stuff
like that but for me I want to know that
it's actually gonna be able to do what
it needs to do in PvE it's like the part
for me where it still needs to be a
factor because if it doesn't do enough
I mean PG&E is fun yes don't get me
wrong but if it doesn't do much in PvE
if it can't take away from some of those
other ones it's not gonna do as much
solo mode it's a breaking hearts last
night nah man
okay what gun you was using I got a dope
talk to me slow but you using a banana
that you break a heart sweet good but
yeah it's just I now want to know how
those heavy machine guns do in PvE
because they are going up against some
powerful stuff yes like whispers beyond
broken I mean if you're gonna make me
pick thunderlord over whisper or sleeper
for anything that thing's gotta be a
beast
it's gotta be a beast I think what they
have to do is see it for PvE to work we
know pvp is a beast it should they
should keep it as it is it will be fine
if it acts if you reacts the same way
but MPD maybe they give it some type of
intrinsic perk like I'm you know what
you know what I'm thinking like a like
go with the meta of the weapon under low
ever I remember we had like silo
supercell and it used to like shut out
two other things it's like a little
electric field and you know maybe throw
a rampage or you got to do some extra
things to make it flashy in PvE and then
I think you find that that medium what
do you think yeah I mean it's gotta be
something to me big because I mean
you've got it's going up against such
heavy hitters thunder it'll be like oh
thanks like you've got to make me care
about the gun and if you don't that's
gonna be kind of a problem because well
they're gonna be fun to use in PvP you
just because I usually will have more
ammo and possibly more kills on the
other side it's just like if it doesn't
Wow me it's gonna be hard to switch to
like what is gonna be its appeal when
I'm going to go fight you know a prime
evil or go take out some guys in gambit
it's like if I go pop that heavy it's
got to be good yeah absolutely
actually not would you I think
making a valid point it can't but what
we're saying is it can't return in the
exact state as we known it from day one
it would have to do other things so
we'll see loosely we know when pvp is
gonna be stuff that i know yeah i was
like i'm can't wait to use that thing
you can get those machine lord medals
just start those things that's good
stuff finally of course he got spring
and they got summer so usually it's nice
that we do have three things planned we
only had literally you had osiris then
you had like six months till basically
war mine it was an a so it's December to
May so it's a long time so the season of
blank the penumbra which is that whole
shadow and light and different things
going on getting us another raid layer
again giving us that little like you
know push back into summer getting ready
for whatever is gonna come in September
shout out so the guys working on
September I do not envy you right now
because the bar for forsaking is off the
charts a new activity experience again
these are just kind of those things
they're gonna add and more other stuff
as well so it's like we there's a lot
coming and to me me being a destiny
two-player this seems worth every single
penny absolutely I mean I just like I
was just saying like in my mind this is
an easy sell for other people it's like
they're gonna want to see it but to me
I'm like this is a lot of crap for 30
bucks yes yes no I agree I agree man I
just like that steady stream condom em
before we would have their December then
you gotta wait so long and then after
the spring is like so long and you're
basically just waiting for the next
expansion we get kind of like a very
light free update you know maybe late
spring summer but you know this is just
boom it literally feels like yo I'm not
even done with with with forsaken like
we're getting close I mean we're not
that you know we're at the end we
getting towards the end of October
November is gonna be here in a minute
you know December's right around the
corner you know and it seems they keep
they still have things do that again not
that this is a bad thing this is great
but it just goes to show you like the
the content
space that they are in when it just
pumping things out and it's just so much
I literally and we'll get into the
festival like I literally have not had
time to touch it like I've just been
doing other things but that's just me
I'm not
peanut and camp at night but at the end
of the day that just shows a good place
that inside is really a ton of
activities do yeah so I mean for me I
can't wait to see what this thing brings
they know some people are gonna wait but
all in all I'd say this is gonna be
hopefully a really awesome year for
destiny it'll definitely start it off on
the right foot
hope so like you said you gotta keep the
momentum poppin they cannot have they
cannot afford to have a curse of Osiris
moment you say that oh like that and
that's kind of one of the things that I
think they might be probably the most
fearful belt which is why I think
they're gonna have to do nothing but
absolutely just blow this thing away
because Osiris was literally what almost
broke destiny too I mean and it took
them so long to get to war mine they
have this schedule they've got to hit
they know what's going on now they have
more people working with them so like
you know black armor it could be for
anything good like Vicarious Visions
that you've got high Moon Studios could
be working on gambit and they could be
rotating through all this stuff so I've
got some more help to work on quality
stuff but if you pull on Osiris again
you're gonna you're gonna lose so much
that you've built you can't do it wrong
there's no way you can do it wrong
absolutely
get into it yeah so that long tangent
aside long what I mean it's like you got
a lot of stuff going on so I mean the
bar is up their high they've had done a
lot of great things and if they keep
this going they will continue to stay
relevant through anthem for Division two
and other things if they do it right if
they drop on Osiris then people are
gonna be like what's that other game out
there like as soon as they can as soon
as they can absolutely the fact that
they're still kind of they're still
rocking in the midst of a Call of Duty
they still rocking in the midst of a
great Odyssey now I know we got Red Dead
that that's the one that's a bit
it's wriggling there ya go but you know
generally you know with those type of
questions people are gonna be you know
very much involved in a you know great
shaping campaign a couple you know weeks
or whatever they blaze out and usually
with the single-player games at least
when Destiny's good in my experience
people have always come back and that
you know two-week period after they've
kind of plays that
you know kind of thing so again Lucy but
we shall see again it all depends on
that content how quality of it so let's
move on to our next peak basically this
week of destiny is insane yes the week
of October 16th is got to be one of the
craziest ones and almost probably since
forsaken came out I almost want to say
it's worse yeah forsaken was literally
the release the raid wasn't even here
yet
we were grinding through the story just
getting a feel for everything that's out
there but in all honesty there's so much
to do this week I literally am NOT gonna
do it all there's no way Oh in world
there's no way so what have you been
doing let's let's talk to you first oh
how many fans you're gonna be mad at me
cuz there's been new first of all to
loss touching for me because the way the
way I looked at it was this I just made
a business decision I said as I looked
at I looked at festival laws I looked at
the reward I said oh horror story origin
story kind of thing rampage and I want
it I definitely want it but I was like
is it gonna kill me to grind it right
the first week and the key was that
festival is gonna be around for like
three weeks right so once I got that
information I'm okay I don't have to
rush banner right now for me I know
people make them crazy because a lot of
people you a lot of you guys love
festival but banner for me is definitely
was the probably already get to all that
powerful year short period of time get
the double xp triple XP you know knock
that out he's thousands only here for
that week so I figure if I knock out the
salad and stuff get that done then I can
double dip and by that time or you you
know a festival the lost child our guys
will figure out great strategies to tell
me that's how I'm rocket this is I'm
assuming you don't write in the PV I
know you PD my biggest one that I wanted
to do which is why it's the unfortunate
week of all time was the shattered
throne I had to get into that and a beat
it that still probably one of my
favorite pieces of content for
forsaken Wow
[Music]
that being a three man the scale the
fights the man rate right three base
rate basically a three man raid and
something note like we had no
inclination or notion that it existed
because we had crazy story we had a
gambit we had the rate BAM
what the hell is this oh this is amazing
just in case you didn't have enough
stuff to do so we got to last time I
went through it I was probably 550 and
not to the point where you're fighting
the ogre and it literally kicks up to
580 at that point the first section you
can probably do it about 560 or so I
don't know 560 or five seventy but we
were under leveled but it was manageable
because you're running around finding
the symbols which is cool because it's
gonna get a tease about the raid symbols
you get to see the different pieces and
you're like working through the ads some
of them just absolutely smoke you but
the area's really cool you're jumping
around and it's just the scale of this
place is bigger and you're like how big
is this place do you work on the first
section you're going through and all of
us and you're like okay I've got to walk
on tiny little like rails up in the
ceiling not fall down it'll push you off
a little form and then you get to a
point where like okay now I'm like
you've got to basically do a gauntlet
you got to survive a constant onslaught
of little thralls while you're slowed
and can't jump and if you're under
leveled those things would just
absolutely start right it was we're
basically in one shot maybe two and we
were linen supers so this time coming
back through it like 585 almost 590 I
think both of my two over 590 now so I'm
gift linking up there it was definitely
a lot more manageable but don't it was
not easy by any stretch of the
imagination so then we got to the boss
room we fought with that ogre room for
quite a while I mean that was just
kicking butt it was it's brutal
I mean I've seen it and do it smoothly
and we kind of because what you there
are four wizards and you got the ogre in
the middle ochre is yielded until you
take out all four wizards
if somebody gets a buff of basically
times four and you can drop his shield
gotcha now you can do it I think four
times we did it week I think we killed
him in like two rotations because we had
some whispers
and stuff um but just getting one full
rotation there's not the most cover in
the world then the ads that spawned you
always have to vandals and to goblins I
hate goblin takin shielding oh my god do
I ever yeah worse that's the worst so
but so we kind of we were trying to
clear out the groups all together and
then we were trying a different strategy
of like okay killed like rotate through
the ads but leave the wizards up so then
when you go to do the wizards by
themselves they're not quite as bad we
tried both we ended up just going groups
but I mean that fight alone you're like
okay go through the wizards trying to
hide and cover make sure you're not
lying aside the ogre and it's not overly
crazy mechanics like the raid I mean the
raid is like okay you all this stand on
the platforms don't in sit like the
Calley fight alone I could talk to you
for like 30 minutes if I was explaining
all the details it's not that bad but I
mean for three people there's definitely
coordination okay you pop your healing
rift here okay do this hold out here and
switch over okay pop up your wall here
so our back is covered so I mean you
have to have that communication in that
piece and it was honestly just so much
fun but also an absolute challenge that
destroyed destroyed us the left I mean
oh it was well the last time we were
like nope and honestly I loved that they
had something in there that was that
hard and that high yeah absolutely
fons give me credit man he said
appreciate your ancestors working to
like the way you present them and he
doesn't mind yeah you don't mind dying
mortal we feel like you know wait like
he's showing some humanity here like
he's showing bunner ability we don't see
that with these kinds of creative they
act like everything's purpose no II
wanted to show you a little slip-up here
and there but you get right back when
was a he will continue to do that thing
the solo way so yes Fonz I agree BOTS
guys tons of credit for that
well thank you guys very much it's one
of those that if you're going through
you're like well not a perfect run but
everything else was mostly those for
sure so I felt good as a warlock what
doesn't yes okay okay so you know either
at least they didn't make me feel like a
complete you don't say loser I was like
he can't make a mistake once in a while
we just love it over good yeah so I mean
it's just one of those pieces that
there's a ship so there are four
triumphs for that place there is a
flawless for your group there's a solo
solo which at some point I want to try
this weekend just because I should be
high enough to finish it but I know that
solo is going to be brutal and it's
definitely gonna be long but there's a
solo flawless mmm that is gonna be one
of the hardest challenges I've gotta try
when you put in that video up already
you know you do with that video is gonna
be like two damn hours long already in
like the first week it was up cuz he was
six hundred it was not human as that's
an Android let's talk about real human
beings it's like I understand all the
points now it's probably the hardest
part I could honestly manage the last
fight solo in my mind
easier than I can probably manage that
more the ogre fight the ogre fight is
where you're where I'm probably gonna
die the most enjoying it so it's like
there's gonna be a solo final completion
and then it's like alright if I can
finally figure out the solo flawless is
gonna be hoof but yeah that'll be I mean
that's like one of those things that
I'll work on for a long long time for
that video man I know you can do it I
know it I know just the fact that they
threw that challenge in there I love it
yeah I love the fact that they actually
are like they made something that a
person's solo that's literally a
shout-out to the crazy people like I
mean I'm somewhat crazy esoteric is
insane but just the fact that they have
it in there I think is really really
cool and it also gives people who are
like if you don't have anything else to
do but you want to hit every single
[ __ ] heads up you about to face a
really tough challenge so it's just it's
such a such a cool place sorry that's my
rant I had to talk about we spent it was
2 hours and 16 minutes for our full run
so it was no joke like even kind of
generally being able to look up what the
strategies are how it all works still
definitely took some beatin and we were
five 80s we were
I was probably 580 hi not quite 590 by
the time we were running that and then
my other I think one of my buddies was
580 straight up and another one was
probably low 580 so we were all in that
five 80s range and I would probably
after that first section I wouldn't even
tell you to go try much after that don't
try the ogor unless you're 580 because
you will get smoked you smoked at but if
you can get to about 590 it's because
the final fight is 590 and the closer to
the fight recommended level this time
around it's the only thing I can tell
you to recommend that match that
recommended light otherwise it's almost
not worth the frustration yeah I
appreciate I appreciate that man I will
definitely get in there man like I said
only dabbled on it briefly but um yeah
man like are you up to right now right
now I'm just been like man I think my
problem right now is just chard economy
I'm waiting for that update waiting the
next Tuesday man cuz I've like 580
chillin but I haven't got a chance to a
lot of chance to to play as much as I
wanted to but I've been kind of unlucky
with the which drops and when I finally
do get higher light level it's like
really not the black like a three point
two four point jump that I need and then
I got two points so my things like you
know what I'm just gonna hold all this
like I have a whole bunch of stuff ready
to put me to 585 590 but because of my
lack of course I'm like you know what
I'm gonna wait because it's um literally
just sitting on a whole bunch of enthuse
right now you're gonna zoom so that so
pretty much I'm waiting for Tuesday's
update see if they're gonna really
include more masterwork or sources don't
feel bad slow-mo my father don't feel
bad bro wait until Tuesday they will
drop out that patch the next patch which
should address spider bounties giving
other sources of getting masterwork
course cuz that's really the hold up you
know I mean I can literally get up to
600 in no time the problem is I have to
make very stringent decisions based on
my lack of course and economy
yeah I mean it's for me is like it's
been every little piece that I can I
haven't done a full rate I've done
partial I got some big drops from the
that's the other place I mean they're
raid level drops from shattered throne
yeah if you go in even if you don't want
to go bash your head against the ogre
for a little while yeah if you can get a
group in and just go work that first
section and so love that one reasonably
and that might be my first guy just be
like hey even if you're five sixty four
one of my what was it the the dark
monastery video that I did I lowered
myself down to five fifty cuz I was
literally like hey I know not all of you
guys are up there so we're gonna go do
this at five fifty place that audit of
night who's five ninety and see what it
takes to kill him so I might honestly go
in at about five sixty or five seventy
something like that a little lower and
see what kind of a reasonable level is
to fight that first section because if
you're looking for a boost it's gonna
give you a pretty high bump cuz I won't
I got a drop out of there was like six
or seven levels higher and that high up
there smaller but that is still one of
the biggest bumps you'll get is in there
if not the rate so if you need a little
bump for gear go do at least that first
part that's - absolutely yeah so you
haven't touched the haunted forest right
so please yeah do tell me I'm very clear
I got questions for you like you know
tell me as a you know the Osiris fanboy
like how how is there take of this
infinite force like how is this even fun
is it fun this is what it should have
been okay okay alright least a step
towards what it should have been I won't
say it's perfect
it's timed so in my mind it would be
nice to actually see the timer removed I
like how the masks have a purpose
because they definitely do you actually
level up the masks benefits as well so
you have three different main part trees
you can pick from and as you level those
up you get more benefits out of them so
there's one where you do more damage to
nightmares which is like your boss on
each wave so first you'll pick that when
you get more you know damage to the
nightmare the second level of that one
once you kill so many nightmares you get
grenade and melee energy
from precision kills so that's a big
little boost then the third tier which
is the last one I got to finish up on my
first mask is even more damage to those
nightmares so just the fact that the
mask alone give it a cool effect is cool
is nice I'd like to see that type of
leveling would be really really cool for
like so many different pieces of armor
that would be nice
hold on one second news flash in the
chat I need confirmation shot shout to
Jimbo he's dropping some some heavy
things about this festival I need
confirmation he's saying haunted forest
is giving seven master work courts is
this true I don't know I haven't
finished the weekly bounty okay okay
okay ID calls it the worst way if that
is true how difficult would you say is
the weekly barely then it's just crying
it's just time it's not bad I know it's
worth it's worth a lot Mads gaming
what's that make it zebra [ __ ] man this
is what osiris introduced for should
have been this activity is it still
procedurally generated in the same
fashion that Fred just confirmed seven
master records confirmed all I am doing
that thank you guys I guess I will be
touching a little bit much yeah the
masks are really cool now I won't say
this is perfect because to me the time
limit almost takes away some of like the
fun the time limit school for people
like speedrunners and glad and you know
the Slayers and stuff like that who are
gonna be like alright perfect build
stuff like that there's a solo version
there's a match made version now this I
actually like you can go you go and it's
basically a closed fireteam so
whatever's in your fireteam or imagine
making have the option in there I want
them to do this on more things mm-hmm so
that's a cool thing but there's no way
in hell a solo person's ever gonna get
to level 15 in the same amount of time I
don't know sheriff esoterics get like
you don't have the time how to do that
so those where you know what's up scream
some of the people to name we got my
Shari we got McFly MK is good to see
really need to like to see you guys you
have no idea but each wave you go
through gets harder so first we'll start
out with some easier guys and it seems
like the health on the nightmare seems
to get to be a little bit more the
nightmare seems to rotate through most
of the big guys that you would expect
he just chases you just like the boss is
at the end so what you'll do is you'll
work on a percentage so if I kill red
bar guys they're like 1% of the majors
they're gonna be like 5 the Damon's as
you're the infinite forest they are
gonna be they're gonna be a bigger chunk
so those guys definitely have some
health but you work them down and
they're worth bigger chunks you need to
give them 0 to 100% when you get a
hundred percent wherever you're at in
that world that you know branch they
call them you'll teleport to basically
like a circular platform with the boss
so you'll be there ads will spawn boss
will spawn melt the boss down that's
round 1 come back out walk back out to
basically another vex you know platform
you stand on and lights up he is if
you're going for like a record time if
you really want to make the most of it
when you come back out of the boss room
the timer is not running so you could
wait get your super up get everything
charged and then kick off that next
round if you want to be 100% efficient
and take your time in there that's how
you do it guys you really wanted to wait
on your super to be full every single
time that me what you do so you can do
that and then as you go through and kill
more and more waves you start getting
modifiers against you come in and
they're not always the same it's
different every run so some of us just
ran on that and sometimes you'll see a
hive one where it's a whole bunch of
curse their own then other times you're
gonna see a whole bunch of synturion's
or minotaurs that are just absolutely
wrecking you
so it isn't random all the way you go
through out
and I would say this thing I think you
know Dada kind of said as well I don't
know if this would be something that you
would want to do forever frightened
right ranky let me put your goods it to
the test now would you head to the wall
we got to see now if you had to rank
this blind well escalation protocol
where does the haunted forest rank
because it actively uh blind well
haunted forest and then top would
probably be escalation mmm
ok so you got it like right in the
middle yeah right okay cool I would put
it in the middle because escalation
still to me has a lot of mechanics and
stuff it adds up the bosses are kind of
unique and it feels more worth it I
guess and it would be I think if this is
a longer piece where it had yep cursed
Co but literally just said it better
loot in the Haunted Forest haha have you
been looped in so that's the piece like
working random for the 600 Auto rifle
which is cool I mean it's a guaranteed
circuit if you own forsaken it's a
guaranteed 600 and you can spend your
time and grind for it doesn't matter
what level you are because it's like a
200 activity it scales you down so it's
a cool thing to be able to get but if
they needed it to be long-term they
would need to be like triumphs for
getting up levels you know clear a
hundred branches for this there'd be
bounties in there you could do it for
every week there'd be you know a
powerful gear that you could work on
grinding for those type of things is
what would give it legs and links that
it would need but yeah a horror story is
not enough because it's like I know over
the course of three weeks uh Levin
should get it not that concerned some of
the masks are cool but I think to make
this longer term to really be like hey I
got up to like wave 75 today you're like
holy crap how long were you in there be
like I was in there for like four hours
man
that could be something like a solo
person could sit there literally work on
for hours and but if you got up to 75
say like every 15 20 levels you get a
piece of powerful gear that's you I mean
just find your way to make that thing
worth spending the time on and make
those like put the carrot on the stick
out there it has potential I would say
this is what this is what
infinite forest should have been from
the start this would have given mercury
more legs than it ever had now oh I got
it I gotta cut you in say cuz we have
Texas representation in the ILP chat I
had to slough some non destiny clauses
in here showing some glow so shout out
to Jake dub in here in the Church of the
Lord's getting that Destiny flashpoint
salute you brother and of course the
diabolical silver sky five four five
that is what's up good to see you guys
yeah that's the guys like that yeah I
know I know service guys about to see a
baby is loves I had to he said I'm at
work
wishing that I could watch them okay you
don't watch a daredevil benefits me
brother thank you building we had to
show some love out here yeah so I'm sure
my chat said it pretty well
escalation protocol is fun but you can
barely three-minute you do need that
time where you get like five six people
where there's a whole bunch of people
sitting around because there's there's
just a lot of crap going on so I mean
three is tough four is better and now
that we're over leveled it helps but it
does have some of the best weapons in
the game so that grind the you are gonna
bash your head against that wall cuz you
want what's there the other side blind
well is fun but after the bounties
what's the point so yeah I mean like
what's the point in doing blind well
because after you get your piece of
powerful gear or your you know
transcendent blessing purification
ritual and all that stuff there is less
purpose to do it so that's kind of the
balance between them and that's why I'm
wondering if these expansions are gonna
have activities that have legs and links
to them it's like escalation protocols
cool but okay say if you had all three
weapons and then like the armor set
really doesn't ever help you that much
they need to have specific reasons like
if there's an escalation protocol armor
set it needs to have like you know maybe
a unique part to it yeah I think this
yeah I agree which won't help so as that
type of stuff and it is a when you play
it you'll have to let me know because
okay there's some cool pieces to it I
like how it's how it has a lot of
potential is a perfect no but I think it
also can is what a lot of people wished
what we had from the start so fan that's
so cool like for
we were given honestly awesome for a
three-week event great yeah it's cool
they we basically the bottom getting is
they repurpose this content that a lot
of people didn't like yeah with the
infinite force they actually made it a
fun activity is intense and the fact
that you have it over blonde well and
like I said I don't I don't despise
blonde and well but I do agree with you
where you rank it but I mean why you
rank it the way you rank it so to hear
you say that gives me confidence that
probably what a good three main squad I
will enjoy you know I'm saying that
content officially this is cool I'm
feeling it you know just little things
like what they're doing on the mask is
like I knew the mask we're gonna drop
your level down so it's kind of curious
but it's a 200 power level activity so
you're just scaled but I like how those
PETA's perks can actually level up and
this is something like I wish they could
do for like give me more reason to run
the raid and so say get a full raid set
but if I work through and actually build
up like raid clears or boss clears on
the raid and every time you do that
you're working on adding to like an
intrinsic perk or like an upgrade that
you can do to that piece of armor this
is the type of stuff that really needs
to start bringing being in the game more
frequently like the mask what they've
done with the masks give that it to more
cool places just gives us more incentive
to grind but yeah that's kind of my
little piece on just hunt it's it's [ __ ]
early I mean it blows away festival loss
before it's not festival the cost we got
the checklist it's a knockout list
you've got I think ever versus in a
decent spot its Cosmetics but you got
the engrams dropping like all the time
you level and overall I think this one
is a very positive event and this
actually gives me a lot of more faith
for what's coming in the future check
out all the rebellious Lords at work
right now listen to us now have a chat
right now he's at work what are you
doing I'm working I'm listening to you
at the same time killing my internet
connection so just out there everybody
at work yes sir so this guy he wants his
nose a lot that is the man
it's my destiny brethren what does we
but yeah most everything else is the
mask you got the paper mask out there
and stuff like that that are kind of fun
but generally the haunted forest I think
was well done the grind for horror story
is not overly long but still pretty good
so it's been fun I think I was like I
kind of said fright of my chats quote
studying for an exam those are the
biggest fake quotes I've ever seen
you're half paying attention arrange
that as much as you aren't studying just
sit back make some pop-tarts and enjoy
the morning there you go and then most
of the table honestly is pretty light
guys so we're gonna kind of bus whiplash
snow they got jack alight patterns where
you can literally put these on
jack-o'-lanterns so you can actually
like have some destiny jack-o'-lanterns
if you really want to make them they've
got a video about the actual paper masks
that you can get but these are all like
the stencils that you guys can see for
the Jack liners which is cool mm-hmm so
you've got like most of the symbols a
little Forsaken one destiny scorn some
of them are a bit more detailed but all
in all very cool I don't envy anyone
doing the bottom right snake one because
that's a lot of detail yeah but other
than that I'd say it's just some fun
stuff in here they've got a giveaway
going on the Rockstar Energy stuff going
on in game competition so I guess you
earn points for completing matches
defeating Guardians getting precision
kills and I guess the top four players
are in the qualifier around I guess it's
just like putting some time in with
those bounties I haven't even been
paying attention to that's that much but
some kind of cool looking stuff so
you've got hoodies kind of a cool
looking headset with gambit on it you've
got a Rockstar destiny controller and a
damn like mini car this basically looks
like a little track cause yeah so give
away those are astral helmets yo to
watch calls late that caught that's a
real car like what is that so cars like
this usually what you'd take to a track
I mean the wheel in the back seems kind
of obscure but this is more like they
make something called like a Caterham my
brother looked at one once and it's
basically like a motorcycle type open
feel
our wheels because for more stability so
you can actually drive it around but
gives that more motorcycle feel very
light frame probably depending I don't
know how much power this one it have but
it's usually a pretty good
power-to-weight ratio so you've actually
got a really fast little speedy thing so
you get that nice like rush of air in
your face if you've ever heard of like
an Ariel Atom which is the massiveness
same probable principle just kind of a
more stable bicycle or motorcycle mm-hmm
kind of an amazing giveaway piece of
Transportation that is like you get a
car like I guess like a mini Batmobile
they just give it away
no joke those are usually pretty cool I
got some patches they talked about they
got some bugs that were fixed they got
more bugs that are going on some scopes
are being weird Polaris Lance the exotic
perk is kind of broken right now so you
can't actually do the master work I
think that's actually busted at the
moment so that's being worked on overall
if you guys haven't seen this by the way
it's the edge transit of all edge
strains and videos everything to edge
strain something there which is good but
a cloud and I made me seen the knot edge
transit but overall that's kind of the
12 was like honestly it's probably the
busiest weekend destiny so it's also
probably the yeah they can get away with
a light 12 it's just so much to do we
got a patch though got some stuff to
talk about briefly nothing too crazy
that I can tell hunter the one where you
actually kill clip would not trigger if
you use the marksman's dodge that one's
fixed so little pieces like that burning
maul slam triggered melee based perks
you got throwing hammers only can be
picked up if your ability is not charged
I actually randomly though I've seen the
the gift the hammer flying back and
forth and actually saw a guy in a strike
and he was a hammer guy and I picked it
up and then I throw it at him and he
realized what I was doing he threw it
back at me and we're waiting for some
the load forth and I was like I love how
they left that in the game like that
down one was pretty fun warlock so you
guys got quite a few
you're not gonna kill Allen supernova
but you can take these if you want yeah
I grabbed a warlock stuff I mean you
know it's I gotta be honest though
there's still that one that I still have
not seen that I'm still very very
concerned about you know saying we
talked about was it chaos reach you know
I'm saying and yeah and I I don't see
that so I guess I mean I was just one
thing I want to come at me most of the
stuff we've already been through but
again I'm very concerned because again
when when it came out it was it was told
to us that you can cut off your super
and you retain super energy so the fact
that now they have acknowledged it on a
form they have acknowledged it on
Twitter and reddit but it is yet to be
mentioned on a patch note that is
concerning that to me shows that this
the problem with chaos reached cutting
off earlier is offer is a bigger issue
then they can handle cuz I've never seen
them really avoid talking about
something like no I was like I mentioned
it before it's like and it's never been
there never talked about so either
they're like we're probably not doing
that or it is something that's harder
for them to stop and try to find a way
to balance it because if you just like I
mean I guess it'd be one of those things
where how do you balance it for how many
times can you stop it what if I look at
you know if i invade gambit i see
somebody over there blasting real quick
turn it off okay then come right here
work my way around oh I see couple guys
blast blast turn it off like Ryan could
manage a whole lot more lethality for
that thing when it's meant to be like
kamehame for a little while and then
write it down so there's it could be
Opie and I get that I guess I guess what
I had minimum what I was hoping for was
you know again they are the ones that
said when you cut off the super it
should retain its top you know point
that you stop that and you you'd have
whatever you don't waste it because
think the problem with the super is that
when you use it you stand in the air
like a sitting duck and you're very non
you know mobile you're very stationary
right you're looking at something common
coming on your holes you're the left
side right
and back wide open and you're forced to
finish the animation out right this is
what's attracting me from using this
super it's just such again if you if you
see something they're dead
instantly like that part I will give it
in lethality but um again I just a very
concern now cuz like at least at my
things dizzy at minimum maybe like less
than a fourth back at least like it goes
to nothing
oh I can do one second of chaos free to
set up I'm done it goes down to nothing
as if I had no super and I got a problem
with that so we gotta we gotta get that
you know get that going man we gotta get
that going but back to me you know other
warlock updates you know I'm saying
besides me complaining was um yeah just
you know the arm healing rift well of
radiant stuff we're pretty much you know
a white nail from was not working from
this guy the
whisper and you know stuffs wasn't
activating correctly so they're doing
that hand if it's an issue where
handheld supernova could deal damage to
allies I have seen that it's quite funny
fiction issue with handheld supernovae
kills sometimes appear is killed by the
architects in the obituary I've had that
happen as far as the inconsistency on
players are no longer performed perform
the atomic breach melee ability when
using the heavy attack of the escalation
protocol sword I did not know that I
wasn't aware that was bug fixed an issue
in which using the Phoenix Protocol
exotic chest with well of radians could
result in weapons not rendering so looks
like a you are thing can't carry Goa
cares reach casting cares reach with
your back up against the wall who have
no longer blocked the beam glad they fix
that less damage at lower frame rate
console as a result listen
as a result plays made now notice it
increased in tone thank you for blessing
us console plebs with the correct damage
or cancer each must be a mess because
you can't like if you put you up against
a wall you don't get the beam
if you want a console you get less
damage you shut it up early it's not
working like Cass peach must be very
difficult to manage in battles but
that's what I got you can go with your
armor and weapons and finish that thing
off oh you're good but I mean so it's
kinda one of those you're asking about
so take any other super the roams yes
it's basically gonna run for an extended
period of time say a fist of havoc where
you running around the slam what if I
slammed and shut it off
slam just shut it off are you being like
um because you don't here's the
difference with your or fist of havoc
remember you have full mobility to go
whatever you want turn around go back I
have none of that I I jump in the air
now and I'm like look at me and my my
fist as I shoot you from across the mat
not anything in my line of sight is dead
but anything I'm not right do you know
the turn radius is so I have the super
it's so these work man and it sucks
because it's the pen missile cuz that's
a one-timer true but again it's like you
have mobility to fly forward and that's
my one use you can hit guys across the
map that I would be flying towards right
but I can't I was like but it's also one
time bigger I don't know I'm just saying
I think part of them probably having to
put their foot in their mouth right now
is the fact that having to manage being
able to turn something off if you just
like if you see a guy and you quick
blast him and turn it off real quick
then you run around you're doing this
other stuff quick blast and turn it off
I think we know somebody so quick I feel
like that's where the issue is it's like
as for your psyche though they just need
to address because it's technically said
I completely understand all I would say
is if they're very concerned about that
then at least give it bring it down by
default if you cut it off as a default
like 25% or less but don't give me
nothing like that that's just like you
know it just it's just a slap in the
face because it's like what's the whole
point of turning it off early you might
as well just never have it turn off and
then give the super more mobility then
and let me act like a true role
super because it's really defrauding its
frauding as a role name it's really not
you cannot move you you're up in the air
and you're stationary and you can just
turn like you're shining a light on
objects that's what it is you can't get
quite a decent like area covered though
like if you get decently high up in the
air and you've got some guys like down
below you and out farther ahead you can
cover multiple areas as opposed to say
like a nova bomb hits one area and
you're done I think can actually cover
multiple areas not amazingly but it has
a chance to like work a couple couple
points spread to it but no I understand
it's like for you you just like I want
an answer
I just want any never see Bungie do this
and it's like the super I care about is
so crazy because it's that power fantasy
for a while I mean really
Titans live in that realm you got that
you know they have power fantasies with
a lot of their supers this is the first
one I might yeah okay what I'm coming
face me if you want like you want to
feel strong you want to feel good you
can melt with your hand and I guess this
is very surprising that they continue to
not mention it on a table and it's been
like three weeks now like this is very
concerning me so to me again I infer
that this is really game breaking and
they're really struggling with the code
of this thing because I've never I've
never seen this in the history of Bungie
and people are complaining it you'll
mention yeah ups will no longer reload
hand kids if they aren't stowed
scavenger perks a couple pieces of armor
we're like blocking view so they're just
kind of fixing some tweaks here and
there honestly one of my best ones just
for the weapons is Dillon got this one
in there fixed an issue where 1,000
voices would sometimes speak at the
volume of 100,000 voices I love just how
that was phrased yeah it's just a joke
cuz you heard about that like glitch
where it basically like break your sound
yeah oh yeah they had a joke for right
the fix 2002 joke with damage EB they
actually yeah he's like fixed an issue
where one thousand voices would
sometimes speak at the volume of 100,000
voices
so that was he even tweeted ideas like I
was trying to get one little thing like
this and there somewhere and I was like
this was pretty good so just random
tweaks in there most of the stuff is
just kind of fixes they said they fixed
an issue were like dynamics weight
reduction and Zen moment wouldn't
function and like with Luna faction rift
or [ __ ] aim assist on the linear
fusion rifles but they did reduce the
aim assist on sleeper simulant by the
way heads up everybody go do the quest
for the haunted forest at a minimum
because you get a free fighting lion
yes add a list which I have to do
correct that's correct so go do that
because it's a guarantee to have the
catalyst and be done with it Chris
Carrabba said he actually got it in a
random drop he hasn't touched it yet so
I guess it is in the loot pool as well
because the event obviously will stop so
there had to be some other place to get
it but if you just want to guarantee
catalyst and be done worrying about it
knock it out it takes like I don't know
half an hour so it's a pretty easy one
to get other than that just random
little tidbits here and there don't need
to go through them all if you guys want
to check them out you can a couple fixes
for gambit just gambit quitter penalties
have been re-enabled
yes you've got clean engrams not
functioning properly which is good
shield wall is not spawning at the
beginning of match where you guys could
kill each other as you guys know the
changes to iron banner so most of the
bounties are less and all of them are
powerful which is honestly cold and then
you know capturing the waypoint no
longer progresses a little pieces here
and there and overall just like little
stuff so if you guys want to read the
patch notes I try not to read these
verbatim yeah you guys have eyes you can
read I know you're at work but you can
read them later for all items in the
economy a little stuff here and there
like you know fixed initially the last
wish ghost and sparrow we're not
dropping at the intended drop where it's
just little stuff so I mean it's mostly
minor patches that I noticed overall
they men shout out to scout rifles
though we didn't really hit on that
shout the sky rifles 15% there bump in
PvE got a chance to mess with a couple
felt really good you know saying I'm sad
though because um I really want to dust
off Polaris Lance but then now I've
heard that there is a bug with that I
think II made my statement have do you
have it already done no bro I got my
Polaris is late I got them it's not it's
not broken it's if you're trying all the
okay I will say the explosion isn't
working so yeah you're right hey cuz I
just - doc - super perk of it just to
add a little extra sauce to it the gun
is good without it nothing wrong it's
just a you know when you work to get
that you want to get the full thing over
so yeah so I'll put it back you know in
the bench we'll get it out wofully they
get that Jenna fix so we'll see yeah oh
yeah patches out there you got gambit
doing its meatball thing this week you
got shattered throne you got iron banner
you got haunted forest kind of crazy I
know we're gonna work on rambling here
for just a little bit but if you guys
are in chat right now feel free to drop
a question just kind of want to open it
to you guys for Q&A for any of you guys
out there and chat if you got questions
for us couple topics to kind of wrap
stuff up here but how for you has iron
banner been this week because I want to
say haven't touched on lions like house
been just like the playing like are you
so lower you teaming house I mean I've
been doing a lot of solo so um van has
been good I mean I've been looking up
there's been some things out here in
these streets y'all then we got to talk
about the meta has shifted um there is a
weapon man I can't forget forgetting the
name right now and it's not it's not
Lotus tile it's another weapon I believe
it's a radius in chat or something it's
a letter I know what you're talking
about shattered horn or shuttered
shatter horn oh Lord
we all be on the lookout for this y'all
auto-rifle
i think it's an order what this day was
lacing my goal figure that's the first
time I go thickness to the guttering
bone maybe it shatters something I can't
remember look up the kids was owning me
when I was staying away from that beef I
didn't want no smoke with that that's
the only two guns right now that I have
fear over my goal figure is that and um
shout-out to obviously the lunar House
out but don't those guys aren't they
weren't competitive they did the glue
chatter bone yeah
yeah chattering Crisco yeah his sweat
fest you know I like this way so let's
go you know but at the end of the day
just puttin given yeah and here's the
new [ __ ] ashati that's disgusting right
now toil and trouble
yep people can actually get it now they
got that night fog grind in toil and I'm
talking about mapping people like toilet
trouble is just disgusting as a shotgun
like it's worse to me than chaperone in
my opinion chaperones some skill you
gotta hit the head
you know get that you know the hitbox on
that but um yeah that that's the only
thing I noticed um other than that I
mean I don't know if it's cuz of my
skill level when I was carrying teens
and stuff like that in all sixes but I
still did okay yeah I still did okay so
you know yeah we had a couple of ones
who I jumped in and getting like wrecked
off the top but for the most part you
know I was handling because I think
again with banner with the three cap
mechanic and when those wolves oh that's
what I had to talk about shut up I want
anybody in the chat either bars chat or
um or ILP let me know is it me
but when I was playing anybody's play
amends me when you triple cap it feels
like lord saltan Cilan has new audio in
the game and he says something like yeah
let the wolves howl start the hunt like
I don't recall him saying any of this
some iron banner before there were so
many power plays last time through
actually changed that bounty by the way
I don't I'll have to jump in I mean I'm
gonna play cuz triples this weekend
triple Valor starts at noon for me but
okay shut up so the guy in my chat with
his name I want you to read it just
talked about toil is good stuff do you
see that you guys names kill me
sometimes I was like five said Fred oh
my god it's Malloy and then but fuel
he's the 81 that's why are you one of
those on ps4 who really want
to change your name I can only imagine
honestly that's some of the little stuff
they never mentioned yeah they may add
like little audio tweaks in here or the
guns get like a complete patch like all
the guns sound different when they do
like four seconds expansion stuff like
that is the little stuff they don't
mention but always adds just that little
extra you're like oh new lines it's not
every play Madden for a year and you
hear the same commentary over and over
and over it's like they mmm they put
stuff in that they don't have to do they
can leave the guns always sounding the
same and just for reference it's the new
dialogue and I hear from sounding on a
triple power play it's different for
both the aggressive team that has it and
the team that is being power played
against because it's like the wolves are
howling high it's almost over or
something like that like it's basically
this whole wolves are coming for you
theme whenever the power play happens
it's funny here Sal did say that in the
middle of a crucible match I thought it
was a nice touch it's funny so check
that out
least I'm not bugging it is it is sounds
like it is new and you know it's
something that's cool but yeah that's
pretty much it as far as how it's been
you know the meta still been pretty
strong with that I'm still trying to get
my my regex grind I'm taking advantage
of double xp triple excreta all that
good stuff and getting some armor and
some good stuff out of there so that's
been pretty much it for me on that
thanks yeah I mean mine's been I got
shattered throne done which is does a
lot of work because we were playing to
it like hey let's do the nightfall
honored kay that stuff we're getting up
there for the hundred caves by the way
shout out to that being more of an
option now if you guys are working on
your night falls modifiers that are
probably gonna work with a team probably
go for match game and just communicate
so you have one side covered yes English
and then black out run with those three
you'll get a solid buff and now honestly
once you're high enough level because I
was playing with one person was like
five sixty so we only dropped it like
areas like five sixty five so we dropped
it like twenty five points but the like
once you're up to like 600 you drop that
thing like 50
5560 your put yours gonna be swimming in
points after a little while so if you
guys are working on that grind just I'll
eventually when I'm 600 I'll work on
that like you know a hundred thousand
solo which will take uh some work but if
you can't even match make find a couple
people to play with the hundred thousand
is not as daunting as it sounds just
once you're up at a decent level the
multiplier makes basically all that
worthwhile but if you run with those
three and communicate be like hey I got
you know can't even think of the damn
bow the Void bow can remove on tap yeah
I know but it's like hey we got Boyd
stuff okay I got Boyd okay we got solar
you're running you know sleeper for use
you'd take care of that and we're all
run an arc for whatever the signals
gonna be and just communicate and run
through it honestly they've been going
pretty reasonably like I've had yet I've
run with different people different
levels skill level stuff like that it's
really not too bad you guys kind of
communicate they do seem to go yep yeah
extinguish a match game absolutely so
yeah I was like the night falls are cool
cuz those are becoming another option
because before it was just like I just
want to finish the nightfall so the
calamity thank you fred helped us out
right did so I was like that's cool it's
like iron banner I gotta jump in so do
not forget triple Valor starts in
literally two and a half hours through
reset I think actually so spend some
time in there you got seven powerful
gear drops from bounties so just live an
iron banner everything else can wait but
again if you haven't done shattered
Throne if you haven't stepped into
shattered throne step in there yeah and
if you're by yourself mm-hmm
so even if you're by yourself just go
step in shattered throne damn Chris
Cobra almost 200k last night see wow
that sounds like you can start doing it
once you get close to 600 drop that
point let me if you go 600 you drop a
sixty point deficit you're still at the
recommended level and then you have
those modifiers on there you're gonna be
getting to be like 5 X or more it gets
crazy so definitely getting some big
points in there I was like there's so
many cool options right now seven
powerful gear drops just from crucible
that's that's huge and that's why my
behind is in there I gotta get them
valve gaming say I'm a fiend when I see
powerful girl on a map
got that bow let's go but what bank
shoutout like I said Jimbo thank you for
telling me I got I have to do um you
know how to for us for multiple reasons
now obviously to get my filing line
catalyst which I keep forgetting well
you in the eye for my understanding they
give you the fighting line at light
level appropriate right yep I got mine I
like 592 or something yeah so that and
then on top of that obviously getting in
there and don't getting that weekly
whatever the grind is and get that
poppin so I can get the um which got
master work cause I'd I love that
service guys and I'm Destin guy said I
don't literally have no idea what you
guys are talking about you covered in
the realm of the Lord's yeah so I wanted
to ask you this because shout out to you
guys as well
chats been awesome this morning got a
guest coming in a few weeks
don't let it go yet so once we can know
but got a cool guest coming just
somebody I've been in touch with for a
while just a really cool guy definitely
in the Destiny community if you guys are
in this world you'll probably know and
this is a question I want to ask him so
taking a little bit from the ILP cuz you
did it to me and I get to do this to you
oh I'm ready
top three destiny moments since really
since D ones released wow man you put
that slide Susan get kids okay heads up
you guys so for everybody might chat if
you guys haven't listen I'll pee and if
you don't go over there subscribe to
iron Lords podcast but basically what
he'll do if you're on there for the
first half on there he's gonna be like
alright you're going through doing a
cool intro what even plan alright gotta
put you on the spot top five game genres
franchises like Jimmy rec no no yes but
it was like I had to do that and I was
like oh my okay and you just on the spot
you're like I don't know
like you don't know what to say top
three dusty moments this or is it date
II I'm giving you guys like your
same moment so like that is so broad
like alright let's let's get some
criteria or like three or five but I
mean no but it's like what are those
like what has been like most memorable
times whether all memorable times okay
all right all right I would say more
moment because I want like I don't want
to be like yeah my first time clearing I
mean was it your first time like
clearing a raid or something like that
but I want like single specific moments
something accomplishment that me Laura
Cognito has personally done or just know
not everybody else you're you've been
holding the controller in it okay
alright so I'm this is not any specific
order yet cuz I'm just gonna based on a
brief first yeah one of them would be oh
[ __ ] is my goal the first devil
convinced me to buy it okay
without that so what I would say is ohm
getting to the lighthouse was very
special to me I only been to the
lighthouse full full disclosure one dime
that was it and part of the run to get
there I was a sunset warlock and I was
cheesy and my team got wiped did too
clutch Reza's and killed the other squad
that was part of like the eighth win on
route cuz I had some guys up killers
with me now I some shooters they were
good man look man just support role do
you think so I would definitely say yes
get getting to the lighthouse d1 trials
of Osiris definitely one of my top
moments another top moment has to be
Oryx hard mode we were failing all night
yeah I was like f this I don't care if
my ego I don't have that completion I
think it was before we were I was trying
to do moments of triumph or whatever it
was you get a t-shirt and wear that
t-shirt that you needed yeah yeah so I
was like alright and we just had it we
didn't have an organized but we're
messing up it wasn't looking good shout
out my Manfrotto he knows
story like the back of my I repeat it
every time when it comes destiny and
Oryx um we just had a very tight run and
we were like hold on we're gonna do it
we getting sent to this in the plane we
came back he's we go and get the blights
we're doing nothing and we did it and we
beat Oryx on all aboard and that fight
was epic so that is definitely up there
alright let's see let's see let's see I
don't want to just say all rainy stuff
but raids are up there man razor up
there armed that's getting this question
by the way yeah it's it's raids you
don't say so I guess the third one a
capita three I would say that the wonder
of of um of the of the vault just doing
it just like what is this all about pact
will him scream shout out to um screams
from a fourth one after this one well
scheme just made me think about son I'm
an idiot but definitely it would just be
the wonder of the vault of glass just
what is this rate thing that destiny
play is all going crazy about right when
we hit the soft cap and you had to get
to level 30 shout to my squad they
helped me grind through I was strong
enough to get in you get in and um you
just like yo what is this and you delve
deeper the jumps to mystery the Gorgan
atheon fight you know and then the drops
the legendary drops just like you know
the fate printer and you know like the
mythic class just all these legendary
weapons in that raid and now you're like
yo I have to do this every week because
this guy got this and you know I'm
saying like so that's why I vault is
very special to me it's just it was just
so well done a great introduction to
endgame content six people you know and
you're gonna fight with your people
you're gonna you're gonna you know
everyone has their own idea or own
strategy of how to do things great and I
gotta say because of the classicness and
shout out to scream from mention in
drops my first Gjallarhorn oh my lord oh
my lord that gun was elusive the elitism
that went on with that gun
when you got it how powerful it was in
its initial form Gjallarhorn is special
Gjallarhorn was so crazy that
lfg groups would say they would treat
you like an outsider
no Gally no carry you're not getting in
here so um yeah man I mean Gjallarhorn
is iconic when it comes to destiny it is
there's there's nothing just the way it
looked a mole was just majestic rocket
launcher with the wolf's head and the
tracking the Wolfpack rounds they had
the nerf that thing that thing was so
beast like Gallo on his special so you
know I can I can do for for right now if
I think of a fifth one I'll let you know
but I'll stop at four those are my four
lighthouse Oryx hard mode a Theon just a
whole raid of the vault of glass as an
in-game content and of course the iconic
Gjallarhorn rocket launcher bondage all
right first one for me has got to be -
Manning crota oh you savage play we're
like hey we want it and we flawless tit
- that's how we flawless tit so he's
lawless - man crota because we're like
alright let's go and let's learn these
fights see what it takes and work our
way through trying to figure out what it
was been a couple hours and honestly we
did it like in a night even a couple
hours worked on it that we're like going
through and it's that moment of you're
like okay who's running the who's
running the sword who's on the back wall
shooting that Rockets make sure in the
right place make sure it's good and it's
just it like it came together for us
like quicker than I ever thought it
would and then when that happened you're
in that clutch moments like alright you
gotta jump up jump down okay wait for
the call-outs just talking to each other
working there is you and one dude like
about to finish a whole raid it was so
so crazy so you had to maining crota
like the whole thing was one of my
really really like almost my best
friends was awesome that's one of the
coolest ones because that is how we got
the flawless trader which most people
still didn't have
classic achievement rota - yeah yeah see
I can't say lighthouse cuz I was
literally back back there and I know it
so go there but like Lionel it felt like
they were so good of the two people I
played with that I felt like I could do
more but just being with them showed me
how crappy I really was the levels on a
different absolutely different level of
that game I don't even understand how
you guys are getting away with what
you're doing right now but like hats off
to you because thank you for the
backpack so yeah well I can't do it's an
awesome moment it was only there one
time but it seems like it's hard it's
like hard stuff
that's cause like for me probably almost
it's got to almost be soloing one of my
first night falls when I couldn't I and
I can't honestly tell you which one it
was because it's been so many of them
that literally is one of the reasons why
I have a youtube channel soloing a
nightfall getting the feel for it
spending the time to check out the pyro
gaming as well so one of the guys who
kind of gave me one of my first shoutout
to give me a little boost but the way he
kind of described me is one thing I
didn't even realize I was doing it's
just literally my mind how it works
sometimes it was the shield brothers
that's actually that's gotta be one of
my better solos is the shield brothers
nightfall so
that's the birth of ebon system stop
birth that's when I gave me the title
despised it oh that so many times it's
like depending on what modifier is up if
like specialist was up that week or
whatever and you could snipe in and be
like okay get your powerful sniper get
your three shot I still didn't have the
when I was doing some of that can't even
think of a raid sniper from Wrath but
because that was actually really good
one oh yes I know what you talk about
yes because that'd be like really good
perk for but I was like at the point
where it's like okay three sniper shots
you want to do about a hundred and
eighty 185,000 damage get that first guy
to move turn around look over here and
wait for these guys a rocket these guys
wait for these three play ring around
the rosey with the guy while you're
working his health like be my my
spinning night falls when I crossed that
one off big one that was a big one now
for me I'm almost about to shoot myself
in the foot cuz that's actually not the
hardest one I did don't do me a hardest
one I ever did and I got someone to
delete a character for it out of sheer
accident
so somebody literally put a comment in
my video because I soloed the hell was
the big shank oh oh I know you talking
about we they had it had exclusive drops
with that shake yeah so that strike and
I did it on like my Titan for whatever
week it was it was crap modifiers and I
did it on my Titan I was like alright I
got through it
holy crap somebody literally put a
comment and I was just like hey and I
didn't even realize really know it was
there but I think I was working on it
anyway mhm
and it's like hey if you could do this
on your hunter even the same week
because hunters are still just squishes
he'll they always work you can do this
on your hunter cuz it was like next to
awful modifiers sabers yes thank you
thank you thank you it's Megan yeah yeah
if I could do this so if I so loaded on
my hunter
they're like I will like either delete a
gun or delete one of my characters and
literally likes it before I can even say
hey don't do it yeah literally like sent
me a tweet showing me the delete gif and
I was like oh my god wow that's crazy
so like between the two night falls
those are definitely up there for me
just because those are no brothers like
I learned that strike to help screw with
that boss but save it with my that was
one of those that I just one of those I
bashed my head against the wall for
hours so those are definitely up there
and then probably I actually haven't
finished last wish yet so I know that
he's probably gonna be up there when I
do it full and legit because no people
are choosing it but yeah I gotta say
hard mode Oryx is so much orchestration
and honestly because typically I'd be
like I don't really care who's in there
I'm gonna run yeah because I was good at
running I was honestly yeah running the
plot like doing the platform like me
like that guy was like I was faster than
I'd be like watching people up there and
they're almost getting the time to do
like I'm dropping down before the ships
even God like is really good at that so
and that was being able to run array
being the one who's got to do those
couple moments in the clutch when you're
doing what's the big golgoroth I got to
the point where I'd be like all right
all five of you go down there I'm gonna
solo this part I was so lonely taking
all the shots and then breaking the
thing above because I had like it was
either pulse or auto hit his back
pull his attention it'd be orbs and then
switch right over to my heavy which was
Coulomb's terminus I think I would
certainly and then pop the orb and all
five would be down there so we'd get so
much more damage because all we're
waiting to shoot so I was like when I
got those pieces
so yeah keys fall hard that one soloing
and honestly so low in the nightfall and
then the two-man crota
those have got to be mine up there good
put me on the spot man
you chat made fun of me hey kudos they
said that Fred
yeah everybody else is - yeah guess that
we do have on there that question is
because I like does I mean most of us
who I think would probably be in this
long enough have been doing it for a
while yeah absolutely absolutely but
yeah
so what did it kind of kind of wanted to
throw that one out there so we won't do
that obviously every time but yeah if
we've got some guests they'll get to see
that one oh yeah so it's gonna be
November 9th will be the guest
definitely looking forward to that one
we'll still probably have some others
I'm sure as we work through pretty solid
one chat this morning you guys have been
kind of amazing this morning and shout
out to all you guys who have joined my
world recently yes it's been like just
about a month since NATO came out and
exploded and my world has like doubled
in subs so I'm still in Oscars like side
of things but for me it's been crazy so
thank you guys for all that support
lately but also if you guys are new to
my world Gold join I lords podcast world
as well that's it it's YouTube iron
Lords podcast it can't go wrong if you
like long-form podcasts you're already
here so I know you do and go join the
iron Lord podcast if you like gaming at
all exactly in it since you are like if
you're our age now we're mature and be
been around since 8-bit Nintendo and
stuff like that awesome interviews I
mean yeah shoutouts a kognito just yeah
thank you sir I've got an awesome thing
running over there so reshape the stuff
in there so definitely check those guys
out another way to entertain your week
on Sunday and if you're busy on Sunday
go check it out on iTunes and stuff it's
a great way to knock out usually a
couple hours so it's awesome much
appreciated and it's of those obviously
who love game and I'm actually gonna
surprise him we have a big giveaway
going on so if you forget I just put the
link in your chat guys read there did
you know is coming you know for all the
guys a fan read did you know I love
podcast we have a big giveaway right now
I just put the link in the chat so sign
up like I said subject channel and you
guys get a chance to
enter a digital copy of either on
playstation or xbox if you guys have
those if you want Red Dead this is your
chance and I'm saying so we're doing
this giveaway just kind of giving back
to community stuff like that to thank
you guys rocking with us and man I am
very very happy to do this show up my
brother right here flashpoint is so much
fun chat was absolutely amazing and
obviously every Sunday if we're gonna do
our outro is the Lord's Day every Sunday
and during football season 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time we will have a
guest will actually have Ric lag neezy
and he's the community director of
Kingdom Come deliverance so he community
managed he's going to be on we're gonna
talk some Kingdom Come deliverance but
also we're gonna talk about the new DLC
that draft and chess also regular gaming
what's going on in the gaming community
please check that out Sunday 11 a.m.
Eastern on iron law anywhere we're right
here on the YouTube channel appreciate
support he appreciate the shout out from
Ibanez please all my supporters you know
I'm saying Isla please subscribe to him
and it's the best
walkthroughs in the game the Bob Ross of
Destiny you're never gonna let it go
never gonna let it because that's what
you are a real tough guy high quality
content and the key with him he had
great talks to you in a way that you
don't feel overwhelmed and for a
beginner a person who does not work
working a fire team he is fantastic the
soloist the knife falls to whisper you
got it man and just to see his growth is
is tremendous so my bro very proud to do
the show drew we got a lot of things
cook it well I'm humbled again about the
blush on the can't blush on radio per se
but if you can see me got that sir I've
been trying to figure out because I got
a green screen in a while
trying to figure out a good milestone to
pop my face on some videos let's go I'm
late 20s close twenties actually not as
far as I honestly thought it would be
which is just stupid for me to say I'm
like nineteen thousand one and fifty at
this point so kind of thinking maybe 25
if I can get them asking for a while and
I'd be like might do might do face
reveal around 25 see if you guys wanted
to spread any love or words out there to
get people to sub to see my face nice oh
you guys want to look at it take a look
at neato
these people see me and I got a
character to myself all my Twitter we
got a nose man just like I don't know
it's just kind of one of those that yeah
just probably about that time cuz some
people like to see old faces and it's
getting up there and honestly you guys
probably would just enjoy a little bit
of the ridiculous comments a bit more if
you can see the facial expression to go
we come back it was fun bothering him
and I need to see his live reaction when
I make him cringe so let's get the
petitions up four bodies his face like
it's been humbled by everything recently
and I want to thank all you guys and
just everything we got going just the
chat has been great the growth in the
podcast has been awesome you guys check
it out the channels are both going good
just all good things and I mean that's
news it's a great time to it's just a
great time to be a gamer and honestly
it's a bad time to be an adult that
being said you guys know where to find
me it's he bought us everywhere twitch
Twitter in YouTube if you haven't
subscribed followed either or both of us
yeah do it
you always know what's coming we got
good quality stuff coming to you guys
and Friday is pretty much a wrap so just
about two hours as usual random tangent
to start it out for half an hour
definitely boosted our time but thank
you guys all very very much you guys
have been awesome we will see you next
week and it's all I got
everybody
are you soon